what i want to do in this video is find
the area of the region in the first
quadrant right over here that's below
the graph of y is equal square root of x
but above the graph of y is equal to x
squared so we're talking about
this
region
right over here and we know what the two
endpoints are the two endpoints are when
these two functions equal each other so
x squared is equal to
square root of x at zero
at x is equal to zero and at x is equal
to 1. so how do we think about this
well one way to do it is just to think
about well what's the area between y is
equal to square root of x and the x-axis
so that's going to be and we're going
from zero to one so this is the area
under square root of x from 0 to 1
dx
so this is literally denoting this
entire region
right over
here all the way up to this boundary
point so this entire region and then
from that subtract out this region
the area underneath y is equal to x
squared but above the x axis so from
that we could subtract
we could subtract from zero to one and
those are that's the interval we care
about
the
area under x squared
dx and this would be completely
legitimate and you might say hey look i
have the same boundaries of integration
i have dx right over here couldn't i
have also written this as could i have
not also written this as the definite
integral from 0 to 1
dx
of
square root of x
square root of x minus
minus x squared and if you ask that i
would say absolutely and this is
actually a different way of
conceptualizing it here you're taking
the area and instead of if you if you
conceptualize dx as the width of each of
your rectangles dx is the width of your
rectangles now the height of your
rectangle isn't just the function
between the x-axis and the function
itself the height is the difference
between the two functions so in this
case this would be the width of a
rectangle and then the height would be
the difference between the two functions
and then you would have another
rectangle
right over there all of them have width
dx and then the height is the difference
between the functions and then as you
take the limit as you have super thin as
the as these rectangles get thinner and
thinner and thinner and you have more
and more and more of them you are
essentially approximating the area so
this is one way of conceptualizing it or
just using i guess the tools we already
had the area under the curve of square
root of x subtracting from that the area
under the curve of x squared these are
completely legitimate ways
of conceptualizing it but now let's
evaluate it
so what's the antiderivative we know
from the second fundamental theorem of
calculus we can say that this is right
over here is just going to be the
antiderivative of square root of x well
square root of x is the same thing as x
to the one half power so we just
increment it so we say x to the three
halves power and then divide by three
halves well that's the same thing as
multiplying by two
and we're going to evaluate that from
zero to one and from that we subtract
we subtract the anti-derivative of x
squared is
x to the third
over three and we're going to evaluate
that from zero to one as well
now this first expression if we
evaluated one two thirds times one to
the three halves that's just going to be
two-thirds and then from that we're
gonna subtract subtract this thing
evaluated at zero which is just zero so
we're just left with two-thirds
and then we're going to subtract this
thing evaluated at 1
minus 1 3.
and then
also we're going to subtract this thing
well just to be clear we're going to
subtract this thing evaluated 1 and then
from that it evaluated at 0 which is
just a 0 but this whole thing simplifies
to
just subtracting
and just subtracting 1 3 and there you
have it we get our answer 2 3 minus 1 3
is equal to one-third so this area right
over here whatever you know where you
whatever units we're using is one-third
square units of area